but first up B it's a Pulitzer
prize-winning investigative journalist
writes for The New Yorker his new book
is war on peace the end of diplomacy and
the decline of American influence Ronan
Farrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have had quite a year and you got
retired no I was got a Pulitzer Prize
are you thirty yet I am thirty just
thirty that's old and still got you oh
[ __ ] you you got your first Pulitzer
Prize that's pretty great for you're
working the Harvey Weinstein stuff and
then me too moment and now you've got
this book about a completely different
subject which is really well received by
very serious people about foreign
diplomacy I noticed that the president
spoke to Congress and really echoed a
lot of the thoughts in your book
unfortunately he was the president of
France first what do you think of this
eight play that I was just talking about
between him and what it was going on
there that this power moves of yanking
dusting the imaginary dandruff off the
shoulder I mean this is not diplomacy
and you have McCrone get up before
Congress and talk about Voltaire and Ben
Franklin in the 1700s and everyone's
like yes please more of this we want
professional international relations and
it's just not happening here right now
Trump thinks Voltaire is a Harry Potter
character but okay it seems like that
the Europeans are playing good cop bad
cop with Trump because they have McCrone
come in and they have make-out sessions
and then now Merkel is here who he
doesn't like very much she's a little
spicier yeah and she said something
really interesting she said you know we
can't depend on the United States to be
the leader anymore and I guess that's
where the world is well you know we have
actual metrics on this there was a Pew
survey of g20 countries just in the last
few days and what they found is people
do trust the United States less than
Germany now yeah and why not what I mean
what why do we have to be in that
position that was not something that was
thrown down by Thor why why can't it be
somebody else's turn I mean we're not
still holding the Germans responsible
for you know what are we but I'm not
gonna touch the Holocaust stuff tonight
ever I'm just saying it was a very long
time ago how long did German did Germans
have to say we're not those people
anymore I think the problem is not that
Germany may be taking the place of the
United States in terms of international
relations leadership
it's that China is filling the spaces
we're leaving behind so everywhere
around the world we are slashing our
diplomatic spending we do not have
ambassadors we do not have assistant
secretaries of State who can actually
embed things like this upcoming North
Korea meeting in long term strategy and
what's happening with China is they are
spending more and more on their
diplomats in places like Sudan where
once they were this rapacious interloper
didn't give a crap about human rights
stole all the oil and then got the hell
out of there now they've got a regional
envoy doing shuttle diplomacy trying to
get political settlements in these
difficult spots they've got big big
scale development projects all over the
world they're building everybody's roads
and hospitals and power plants and every
kid in every corner of the world sees
that and increasingly they don't see a
US Embassy there yeah I mean Napoleon
said China is a sleeping giant let her
sleep and there woke speaking of woke
they are woke as held right yeah yeah
but unfortunately not on human rights or
the kind of leadership that I think we
all value and hope it seems like our
problem is the problem that happens with
every Empire first of all we were never
supposed to be an empire and I don't
think we use that word enough America is
an empire unlike any other country now
we have troops in you know over a
hundred countries bases all over the
world some some of these places that we
fought in World War two we still have 40
50 thousand troops I don't understand
why but whenever you have an empire the
the thinking tilts toward the military
as the people who can solve everything
and it seems that is where diplomacy
suffers is because Americans they just
never stop voting for more money for the
military let the military do everything
we put them on a pedestal and everything
else is not what it used to be around
the world it's a vicious cycle we no
longer have diplomatic capacity we don't
have negotiators we don't have
peacemakers and so people do trust the
military more we do run everything
through the middle
and politicians get on the campaign
trail every time and they denigrate I
think people who are really brave men
and women serving the world everywhere
as diplomats you know these people get
characterized as dusty bureaucrats
they're not they are in difficult
dangerous places right alongside our
military it's it's a part of the
encroachment that Eisenhower talked
about all those years ago it's the
military industrial complex it slowly
takes over everything and you know one
of the things I write about in this book
war on peace is I was a little guy at
the bottom of the totem pole at the
State Department in Afghanistan if you
wanted to build a well or reach out to a
community in rural Afghanistan you had
to do it through the Pentagon if you
wanted it done this year and that's a
real problem because the Pentagon is
thinking tactically it's not thinking
about our long-term strategy necessarily
okay so let's switch subjects to your
other big area which is you wrote the
article about how everyone steen you it
was supposed to go on NBC right it was
but it wound up at The New Yorker
because NBC now they're dealing with a
story about Tom Brokaw and and Matt
Lauer and gosh what's in the water over
there and Bill Cosby it's very fitting
here here right after he gets sentenced
or none sentence but found guilty these
were the big fish these were the really
bad people do you think there's an
excess in the movement that is causing a
backlash that's hurting it I'm thinking
about people like Al Franken Aziz Ansari
Garrison Keillor you know I was reading
a story about him and it's day well he
was he had a reputation of bullying in
the workplace that could just be
somebody's opinion and then it said and
on several on one occasion I thought oh
here it comes the penis came out at the
Christmas party
good morning everyone had this pent-up
desire to show their penis that we just
didn't talk about for years and years
and not not everyone but what well done
but a shocking number of people I hate I
don't get the mo but it said on one
occasion he posted an off-color Limerick
and I thought maybe we've gone too far
here so I would just point out I think
that our culture has actually been
pretty good on the whole about
self-regulated so you mentioned Aziz
Ansari you know that blog about Aziz
Ansari came out it was clearly a you
know a single-source narrative about a
date gone wrong and there was a debate
about how far gone wrong it was but I
don't think anyone saw that and said oh
he's Harvey Weinstein this is a multiple
rapist no but he lost a lot early he's
not around anymore is that true I think
so I think his I don't have to ask him
how he's doing these days well I think
we could find that out I don't think we
have to ask him directly but I don't
think his show was on it I just think
that reporting was regarded exactly as
it should have been people saw it for
what it was there was a debate about it
there's a lot of criticism of it I mean
I think people are divided I think a lot
of people are yes you're right there was
backlash and I think he suffered a lot
also from it and and I would say that
those cautionary tales I think have been
pretty well received by fellow
journalists overall what I've seen is
the vast majority of the reporting
that's actually broken through has been
very meticulous has referred to very
serious crimes and you know this
separate discussion of the gray areas
and how far it should go I think we're
sorting that through just as we should
become Franken you think he should
acquit you know I didn't do any
reporting on the Al Franken story I know
I don't know you could have an opinion
yeah you know I do think that it's
correct to distinguish between these
kinds of violations in these kinds of
behavior but I would also just make a
point this whole conversation bill was
under wraps for decades there is so much
pent up your anger
heartbreak and lack of accountability
that I do think it is understandable
that it's coming out in Torrance right
now okay well you're doing amazing work
on a number of fronts you obviously have
your your mother's incredible compassion
and she's great and your father steely
ambitious whoever that may be great to
see you wrote it Ferro thank you very
much
[Applause]